hi Matt here we've got some exciting
news to share think fast talk smart has
been nominated for two Webby Awards one
for best business podcast and the other
for best science and education podcast
and we need your help to win the
people's voice Webby awards are decided
by a combination of judges and public
votes please help us by going to
stanford.io Webby
w-e-b-bby and click on both voting links
it's super easy to do and for fun we're
also running a special giveaway for a
few lucky listeners who vote and share
their support on social media here's how
that works after you've voted for us
take a screenshot of your confirmation
page and post it to LinkedIn and or
Instagram
be sure to tag think fast talk Smart in
your post so we can see it we'll select
five lucky winners who receive our
awesome think fast talk smart mug
thanks for supporting us by voting at
stanford.io Webby and thanks for
listening hi Matt here today we're going
to open up the archive and pull out an
episode that answers one of the most
frequent questions I get asked how do I
speak better when I'm communicating in a
language that's not my native one
join in as we listen back to my episode
with Ken Romeo Ken provides amazing best
practices to help non-native speakers I
particularly like the tools He suggests
and the advice he gives about how not to
strive to speak like a native speaker
enjoy
hello I'm Matt Abrahams I teach
strategic communication at Stanford's
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
having to communicate in a language
other than our native tongue can be
quite a challenge I have the utmost
respect for the non-native
English-speaking students and clients
that I teach in coach I know that I
struggle at times to speak in English
let alone a foreign language
there are some specific tactics and
approaches non-native speakers can use
to handle in the moment challenges that
arise as well as advice and tips that
they can follow to improve their fluency
during this episode we will speak with
Ken Romeo about these specific tactics
and strategies Ken is the associate
director for the Stanford Language
Center and he teaches in the Stanford
continuing studies program Ken on a
daily basis deals with the issues and
challenges that non-native English
speakers have and we're looking forward
to getting the advice and guidance that
you have Ken I'm delighted to have you
join me today you and I have known each
other for a number of years thanks for
being here and sharing your expertise
so let's start at a foundational level
Ken what are some of the challenges you
see non-native speakers struggling with
well it really varies by their
personality
um a lot of people try to be perfect and
when they're not perfect they worry
about it or they try to be perfect by
writing everything down and trying to
memorize it another thing that I see
people struggling with is knowing not
knowing how to improve they have a lot
of faith in books or courses or podcasts
and doing stuff that's really not
interesting or motivating to them and if
you're not doing something that's
interesting or motivating it's not going
to improve you absolutely you know that
point about perfection is really really
important and I think this is an
Affliction not just that non-native
speakers have but everybody has
everybody feels like they want to
communicate right and you know I've been
doing this a long long time and there is
no one right way to communicate
certainly better ways and worse ways but
this notion of perfection and seeing
Beyond it is really important and that
point about passion and is also
important as well those are absolutely
big challenges
have you found specific things that
people do Beyond keeping a journal and
practicing those things that that might
help I'm curious how how do you
encourage people to be curious when they
know they have a deadline or a big
presentation or a big paper to get done
well the basic mindset to take is to
learn the most from your everyday
experiences and not from textbooks on a
really basic level you're not going to
remember anything that you don't enjoy
doing the whole thing about language is
that it's about doing not knowing so as
much as you read and you look at the
rules and things like that until you
actually use that language you're never
gonna you're never gonna internalize it
do you recommend specific tools that
non-native speakers leverage to help
become more comfortable and confident
there's a lot of tools that we have in
our pocket with our phones things like
that for a spontaneous conversation
recording yourself making that
conversation saying certain things will
give you a an objective view as to what
you're doing now we're all embarrassed
about how we sound on recordings but
nobody else has to listen to it you can
say you can put yourself in a situation
where you have to make a response the
key thing here is don't write it down
reading something is a very different
skill than saying something if you want
to be able to read something then
practice that if you want to be able to
talk spontaneously then practice that
use your phone to do that walk around
and take pictures of things if you have
a document or see a sign you're not sure
about the words use your phone to keep
track of your vocabulary there are apps
that help you memorize it to give you
sentences and examples and things like
that so just your phone right there take
full advantage of that tool I really
think this notion of of practice and
leveraging Technology can really help a
lot of times people are so busy fixating
on finding the right word or trying to
find the time just to think about what
it is they want to say they don't take
the time to practice and using
technology can be really really helpful
paired with the notion of trying to get
the language right and the flow right I
really think giving people outlines
rather than word for word makes a big
difference so I tell my non-native
speakers or clients if you need to write
things out just to get the flow and the
grammar right that's okay but then from
that create an outline and practice from
the outline when we memorize we not only
increase our cognitive load what we have
to remember but we also have created the
right way to say it and that puts added
pressure so I'm a big fan of using
outlines have you found outlines to be
successful in the work that you do with
the the folks you work
absolutely I think the outline is the is
the only way to do a presentation the
ideal thing is to be able to have that
outline in your head to know what you're
going to say the best speakers that you
see they do have that outline in their
head and they're just going from that
and they can move things around it takes
a long time to get to that position but
the first step is writing the outline
out working from there I think it's a
really good choice for the first step
excellent can you provide me with two or
three best practices that you've come
across to help non-native speakers feel
more comfortable sure sure
um one of the things I think that's very
useful for a non-native speaker is a
very practical thing that they can all
do is get somebody to edit their work
and then to conscientiously study those
edits and internalize the revisions
nobody's going to be perfect you need
some polishing even I as a native
speaker I need some editing on my work
the thing a non-native speaker needs to
do is to be able to say what did I do
wrong here and then internalize that so
it doesn't happen again another thing to
do is to just cut off your native
language and immerse yourself in the
English that you find interesting if you
have getting your news if you can do
that in the target language in English
or whatever language you're trying to
learn then you're moving forward in a
really important way you're not
immersing yourself in the TV or media of
that of your native language another
thing that we can do that non-native
speakers do uh to sort of level up is to
think about speaking and writing in
paragraphs most of the people that I
talk to are really good with sentences
they can put together a subject a verb
and an object putting it into a
paragraph is really the next level up
you need to have a beginning and an end
and then the supporting arguments in
there people speak this way this is how
paragraphs happen and it's also
completely critical when you do a
writing when you're writing an essay or
a report or something like that yeah
those are great best practices that
notion of having a structure really
really is important and it's very
important speaking as well to just have
that structure that's beyond the
individual sentences a best practice
that I find helpful I'd love to get your
opinion on it is many of my students are
so worried about not having the right
word and what I suggest is do the best
you can and be comfortable repeating
yourself in a different way so you might
make a statement position a claim but
then tell a story or give an example
that reinforces it so if I didn't
understand the point the first time you
said it the story helps me figure it out
so by using repetition not only does it
give you a way to clarify or address any
confusion it actually enhances the
retention of your audience for what
you've said have you found that as a
best practice that can be helpful
absolutely you simplifying it especially
in speaking being able to say something
in a simple way this is what we talk
about with the greatest communicators is
they explain science or they explain
technology in a very simple way a lot of
times with non-native speakers they
learn 100 most commonly used idioms in
American English and try to put them in
all their sentences it doesn't work that
way to be able to use an idiom
skillfully and cleverly takes years of
practice speak simply but also this is
where I go back to being curious listen
to how the other people around you use
those idioms use the sports terminology
in their conversation about business
listen to it study it try it out and
then if you make a mistake learn how to
level to how to move yourself up but
first is simple so that people can
understand you absolutely the the point
you made about listening to hear how
people use language and and use
structure
I want to take a step back and just
remind everybody who happens to be
fluent in the language that they're
speaking we also have a responsibility
here and we need to think about the
idioms we use the analogies we use that
might make it difficult for our
colleagues our friends who aren't up
from our culture and familiar with our
language here at the GSB I tell all of
my students that we have to be very
careful about using Sports analogies in
our business communication it's a slam
dunk push it across the goal line hit it
out of the park that's wonderful but if
you're a non-native speaker and you
don't know what those games are you're
at a disadvantage so while there are
lots of things that non-native speakers
can do to become more comfortable and
confident we as fluent speakers need to
help too by being very conscious of what
we we communicate
any final thoughts you have around tips
tricks best practices for non-native
speakers
think the most important thing for a
non-native speaker to remember is that
they're not going to be a native speaker
never ever but they can get pretty close
through lots of practice and getting
more confident about things there are
times when they do need to be perfect
and it's those times they need to get
help get an external editor get somebody
to coach you on your presentation but
keep working toward that goal and you'll
get pretty darn close excellent well can
I I thank you so much for your vast
experience and best practices you've
shared with us clearly there are things
that people can do who are trying to
communicate more effectively in writing
or speaking if they're non-natives using
technology really taking a mindset of
curiosity trying to reduce the pressure
they put on themselves to do it right
rather than just doing it and using
other techniques to help them come
across as competent and confident
speakers
I hope you're ready to take three
questions that I like to end each of
these podcasts with all right let's
start if you were to capture the best
communication advice you've ever
received as a five to seven word
presentation slide title what would that
title be
it's what I said earlier language
learning is about doing not knowing at
one level that sounds very simple but
that's very very deep it really really
cuts to the point of everything that
you've been talking about so thank you
for that question number two who is a
communicator that you admire and why
I think it's not one particular person
but all the teachers and the staff that
I work with at the Stanford Language
Center they're all well most of them are
non-native speakers of English but they
have absolutely no problem working in
this business environment with a wide
range of students that come into their
classrooms native speakers of of English
as well as non-native speakers of
English to teach them the languages that
they need to teach them so it's the
faculty and staff here at Stanford are
just amazing for the diversity that they
bring and the skill that they have in
doing their job
totally agree it's it's really cool to
see these people in action and to see
the results of the work that they and
their students do to really make people
better communicators and my final
question for you what are the first
three ingredients that go into a
successful communication recipe from
your perspective
it really depends on the person but if I
were to give three words that I think
everybody could sort of make use of it
would be confidence preparation and
revision
ah yes those resonate very strongly with
me and across the podcast that we will
be doing those ideas will be reflected
time and time again well Ken I have
thoroughly enjoyed our interaction I
hope that those listening are coming
away with some very specific tips tools
and best practices that they can use and
it's something that all of us need to
focus on to help non-native speakers be
more effective in their communication
thank you so much thank you it's my
pleasure thanks for joining us for
another episode of think fast talk smart
the podcast
produced by Stanford University's
Graduate School of Business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts